Beetle the belle of the ball after putting
on a pair of Japanese Rhinoceros Beetle Earrings.
And burn rubber on your desk driving a wireless
sports car mouse.
Because it’s episode 54 of LÜT.
The Tiny Tesla Musical Tesla Coil Kit fittingly
allows you to build a tesla coil that can
play music by heating the air and creating
pressure waves we hear as sound. You can order
spare parts if it ever breaks down, and it
comes with a USB connection so you'll be listening
to MIDI Pirates of the Caribbean in no time.
Time to battle some helicopters with the Sky
Terminators RC Helicopter set. a pair of RC
helicopters that shoot lasers at each other.
They have shields to help protect their weak
spot, but if a copter gets hit five times,
it goes down.
If you’d rather build vehicles than shoot
them check out the Air Power Racer Kit. A
DIYtoy that teaches you about using air
as an alternate source of power. The car uses
compressed air to propel itself, and moves
surprisingly fast.
Fill this volleyball court with air on the
water. The aqua glide super volley floating
volleyball court is an extension for the supertramp
35 which means that yes, Billy, floating trampoline
volleyball just became a sport.
Oh my god my name is Billy.
Sport these handmadepumps once you decide
to make it back to dry land. Zombie Peepshow
sells custom shoes, clothing and accessories
ranging from Alice in Wonderland high heels
to Jason from Friday the 13th.
Put water safety first with the Kingii Inflatable
flotation device. Designed to be worn on your
wrist like a watch, the device is unobtrusive
and easy to activate. Simply pull the lever
and a bag will inflate and stay buoyant for
up to 48 hours. And it comes with an attached
whistle to signal for help.
Help yourself to some easy slushies with Zoku.Freeze
the inner core, pour a chilled beverage into
the cup, stir, and then watch as it freezes
right before your very eyes.
HANDIHORSE HANDIHORSE OF COURSE IT'S A HANDIHORSE!!!
But can you drink from the handihorse? NAY!
You’ll need the Magical Unicorn Champagne
Horn to fill your mystical beverage-holding
needs.
If you need a game thats powered by magnets
trythe Hoverkraft Levitating Challenge,
that has you stacking blocks on a hovering
platform. Adjust how stable the hover platform
is, and it plays out like a futuristic game
of reverse Jenga.
Reverse your expectations for what candy should
take like with these Stinger Pops made with
the three hottest peppers in the world. So
pick a pepper and pray you don’t end up
needing first aid.
For those that require cute and cuddly aid
falling asleep look no further than the Sleep
Aid Puppy. A stuffed animal that when activated
lets out a gentle pulse for 20 minutes.
It’s designed to help you synchronize your
breathing and heartbeat so you can calm yourself
when stressed, or fall asleep when tired.
The Beard Bundle will guarantee you’ll never
tire of your beard products. The service sends
a variety of oils, soaps, and balms, and you
can choose from three different levels of
beard care, Minimalist, Lumber Sexual, and
Majestic.
Take in the majesty of Mars from your bedroom
with Mars in My Room. A nightlight that depicts
the red planet in great detail and has points
of light to mark where the mars rovers have
landed. It also comes with a pack of mars
lander cards that give you information on
the different mars missions. Mars.
Then pile more more planet stuff on your planet
with planet plates. Just keep Uranus in the
cupboard if you’re having a dinner party.
After dinner sneak out with the B-9 Urban
Stealth Bike, a bicycle inspired by the f-117
Nighthawk Aircraft. The single speed bike
comes with an atomic 22 security system, which
renders the bike useless to anyone without
the proper key, and its carbon belt drive
is quieter than a chain, doesn’t need to
be greased, and lasts longer.
You can’t ride a bike without some safety
equipment though so be sure to bring along
a chainmail keychain for protection. Which
you can attach to your Konstructor DIY SLR
Camera. A kit that lets you build your own
SLR camera all while learning about how single
lens reflex cameras actually work.
Now that you’ve got a camera light the scene
with the Pixelstick. An LED light painting
wand that you can use to create amazing timelapse
photos. Put the image or design you want on
an SD card, pop it into the wand and wave
it in front of a camera set to long exposure.
But remember, if you get in my way. I have
one thing to say. Don’t stop Meow. Sorry.
And as always - thanks for watching!